hello everyone and welcome to game
number 13 from the 1960 World Chess
Championship match between me cattle and
the Mikhail Botvinnik as you note al is
currently leading by 2 points and this
is game 13 you've probably seen the my
previous 12 video some of the previous
12 games if you haven't feel free to
check out in the description below there
is a link to the playlist featuring all
of the twelve games and if you're new to
this channel if you're new to the me
cartel vs Mikhail Botvinnik match I also
suggest you check out my coverage of the
1959 candidates tournament the link to
that will be also in the description
below so that being said let's let's
dive into game number 13 here as you
remember tall had tall had a lot of
success when he switched from his
usually for in again game number 11 as
he won that game so he decided to go see
for this game so c4 and botany goes for
c5 another thing tall said to his coach
Alexander Koblenz before this game he
said that he was really tired this is
already game number 13 and he could
really use the rest day but I mean it's
not it's not like you can just take a
rest day and he thought that if he's
such a young fellow is tired and
definitely but when he should be tired
as well
so Coblentz I told him to to maybe go
for a nice slow line you know don't do
anything crazy
I just just try and play a quick game
today and we'll continue with the game
number 14
so here Knight to f3 was played in those
days there was the usual line Knight to
the C 3 followed by Knight to f6 g3 d5c
captures Knight captures and Bishop to
g2 nice to see 7 D 3 and E 5 and this
was something Tali enjoyed playing with
the white pieces but the problem was
Botvinnik scored a couple of brilliant
victories so in this line with the black
pieces so as tal was tired he didn't
really want to challenge both unic to
this so instead of Knight c3 human
Knight to f3 and after Knight to f6 now
g3
now if botanique tries to go for this d5
idea
after C captures night captures Bishop
to g2 and Knight to c6 tau had the idea
of going into this variation of the
Catalan with d4 and this was this was a
nice line he very easily played for
white
so after this G to remove a botanique
plays b6 bishop - G - now Bishop to b7
and here castles and here g6g sex at all
believes is the most precise move to go
in this variation of the English
if he goes east sex he gives this as he
gives this a huge variation after d4c
captors on d4 and Queen captures on d4
Knight to c6 attacking the Queen Queen
to f4 Bishop to e7 knife to c3 now
castles rook to d1 Queen - ba - now
swing captures rook captures and after
Bishop - a for attacking the rook rook
to c8 Knight to e5 and after d6 Knight
captures Bishop captures Bishop captures
and b6 Bishop captures rook captures the
Bishop captures King captures and after
rook captures on c4 and rook to d1 then
it's a nice position to play for for
white soul although it can be drawn of
course it's not like white is winning
here but a you know a practice has shown
that white White's did win a lot of
games using this variation in this
position so no wonder botany goes for g6
here we have a d4 now by tau C capture
somebody for couldn't capture some d4
and Queen captures on d4 is a mistake
and this is what why Queen to d4 is a
mistake and night to d4 is much better
here at odds idea is to go Queen to h6
and then go Bishop to h6
Queen to h4 and Bishop to h6 and create
some chances on the King side but here
what an example plays Bishop to g7
Knight to c3 and now nice to see six
attacking the Queen if both Winnick went
thinks that castle here then Queen to h4
would definitely be nice for white
Bishop to h6 is coming next but between
play Knight to c6 and now
Queen to h4 isn't really a good idea but
tal as as he says himself tal was tired
and he played it so Queen to h4 but now
what Anna cause that Queen to h4 isn't
really doing anything he simply plays h6
and now not only is Bishop to h6 never a
threat he's already threatening g5 for
example if you play a slow move then g5
is coming and you don't have a square
for your queen all of these squares are
taken if you go H 3 then G 4 is coming
you lose a piece here so after h6 Tao
tried Knight to d5 and here a botanique
played a 6 and tal says what eunuch
played east 6 because both eunuch was
tired East 6 isn't really a good move
Thal says that knife to a5 is a better
move and he talks about this in his book
saying that it will be very hard for
white to keep his pawn here you know you
can't really go b3 you're gonna open up
an attack from the bishop to the rook on
a1 so this could be very dangerous but
unfortunately for tau e 6 is the engines
favorite move
so between ik even though he may have
been tired definitely plays the engines
favorite move so not something not
something well written by tau in this
instance maybe maybe he was very tired
when he was writing this part of the
book as well so Knight captures on f6
Queen captures Queen captures and Bishop
captures so a forced exchange of pieces
and queens and now rook to be won and
here rook to be won
seems like a very dangerous move because
it allows it allows black for example
Knight to a5 and then Bishop to b4 which
will attack the rook rook will have to
move and then the b-pawn will be under a
lot of attack but botanique had all of
this figured out and tall as well here
935 was played with the idea of Bishop
to e4 b 3 by tau we have Bishop 3 for
attacking the rook and here was Todd's
idea the only move that actually is
playable in this position for white here
top played Bishop to b2 and Bishop to b2
now you can't afford to capture the rook
if you play Bishop captures then you get
Bishop captures and now your rook is
attacked if you move the rook then you
lose another piece here and here you
would have to grab a pawn and after
Bishop captures grab another pawn and
after defending the pawn rook to c8 and
then after Bishop to c3
but captures on c4 and here you would
have a position where black is actually
up three pawns this a a B and D pawn but
White's extra piece is simply too much
here so I black even with three points
black would not have enough compensation
for the piece so this would not be
playable for black so Bishop capture
some b2 was played but also one thing
you have to notice that here when Knight
to a5 was played Knights to be four was
no better for both Finnick because now
white can simply play this Bishop to D
to move and you don't have a temple on
this point if you capture it in rook to
e1 and your knight is trapped
so after this nice to be four instead of
Knight to a5 if what only played this ad
then Bishop to d2 would simply force the
knight back and you know just lose a
move but okay after this knife - if I
move we have b3
Bishop to e4 ISM said Bishop to b2
Bishop captures rook captures and in
this position white is a little bit
better but it was again in this position
that the players agreed to a draw you
know had a terrifying position with the
white pieces
considered a slightly a better position
but he was actually very happy to draw
this game so yeah and that's why I used
this quote above the board as the
curtains the curtain of the Pushkin
theater had been up for 50 minutes but
then it was lowered it must be assumed
to degrade dismay of the spectators so
Esther says the usual struggle between
human between ik lasted for about five
hours but on this day and the 13th game
it only lasted for 50 minutes
so the spectators of course were not
very impressed in 1960 and some six
years later after the game you will not
be very impressed by this game for
watching it on YouTube but as I am
making a series I felt it was necessary
to cover all the games so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it yeah as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and I would just like to
take this opportunity to thank Sean
Wilcox and for sending me this photo
it's actually a photo of his cat Hannah
watching my video here you have a Fisher
versus Petrosyan he said that he was
watching my video and then he just went
to grab a glass of water and when he
came back he found Hannah watching my
video so make it makes me very happy
not only do I have a human viewers but
it seems I also have feline yours
so very nice thank you Sean Wilcox and
and yeah that's it I will see you soon
with game number 14 I think all for
watching and have a great rest of the
day